welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse scenario has turned up some
fascinating overlooked details about the
things that go boom the secret reason no
one tried to put on Starks gauntlet
instead of hot potato we knitted around
an endgame the possibility for reforged
and reach arm to kneel near for a third
world war Thor and the new caps shield
being made out of proto adamantium which
was shortly after confirmed by fortnight
thanks new masters but there was one
even more powerful weapon that quietly
dominated these films tech that
transform Tony Stark is a human being
and arguably Depp the MCU in
non-reversible way is worse than the
snap barf that Tony turned into a
self-therapy machine and renamed by
nearly Augmented retro framing or Barbie
he remade my life's work barf barf
you remember barf sometimes you taste it
your mouth after my theories and you may
remember how back in January 2018 a few
months before Avengers infinity war
released leaked set photos from Avengers
endgame then known only as Avengers for
lend many fans to speculate that time
travel could be involved which it was
cap and Tony were totally time-traveling
in the scene the Russo brothers
responded to these leaks with a cryptic
tease about an important piece of
technology established back in Captain
America Civil War a five-minute sequence
in civil war that they said could give a
hint about Avengers fours plot one of
those leaked photos showed an orange
suitcase labeled barf and we speculated
that Tony Stark's memory technology from
Civil War could be used to help the
Avengers undo Thanos to snap and then
after infinity war and after endgame
we're all so floored 3,000 that few of
us stopped to ask that barf suitcase
that the Rose hose I was gonna be such a
news now and we all said it just like
that
infinity war didn't feature that flip
phone that cap mailed to Tony stankin
Civil War
those risk-based quantum navigators were
a bit similar to the risk-based armor
Tony hadn't savour and I guess Scott
Lang's Pym particles a civil war did you
know factor into in game's plot but no
the Russos teased a 5 minutes of or
sequence it was clearly about barf and
yes of course barf made a huge surprise
comeback in spite of being far from home
but it was a total no-show and infinity
war an end game so worthy Russo's just
trolling us after seeing these leaked
photos and going
and then barfing up some smelly barf
Bologna to throw us off the scent well
actually no barf is visible in in-game
and not just in fat Thor's beard in fact
barf recoded the mind of Tony Stark in a
way that will make you rethink and gain
and Civil War well before we continue
losing your hair is a bummer two out of
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 we don't want that we want
our scalp beards forever with keeps it's
easier and more affordable to get
treatment for your hair loss and help
you keep the hair that you already have
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda-approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy and you don't have to go
into a doctor's office you can just do
it all from home where you're probably
stuck right now meet with a doctor
online and they ship the treatment right
to your home find out why keep says more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors and nearly 100,000 men trust
capes for their hair loss prevention
medications so if you're noticing that
you're losing your hair do something
about it for a limited time goto keeps
calm /nu rock stars or click on the link
of the description to receive at 50% off
your first order okay so where does barf
appear in endgame now again there was
that orange suitcase labeled barf
spotted and leaked set photos that same
suitcase or a very similar one shows up
for a split second right after Tony
returns to Avengers HQ returns to shield
a cap and from his trunk he also removes
a red suitcase which looks a lot like
the one in the set photo when you
account for the color balancing they
probably did on this scene I believe
Tony Stark dusted off his old barf tech
to brush up on the history of his own
life and the life of his father Howard
in order to relocate all the Infinity
stones throughout their points in
history remember during the time heist
after they lost the tesseract Tony
manages to recall on the spot a
secondary destination in the year 1970
we got it there's another way to retake
the tesseract and acquire new particles
well stroll down memory lane know that's
her installation Garden State I know for
a fact they were there Tony never goes
into more detail on how he knows what he
knows but the truth is as Tony prepared
for this time heist he crammed with barf
back an Iron Man 2 Tony reviewed archive
footage of his father
1970s and a young Tony showed up in that
footage is a boy so he could have used
barf to reopen that childhood memory to
objectively review where his father was
in the 70s in order to know how he knows
to go there an end game but here's the
thing about barf it stinks but really
it's not objective it's subjective
during our Civil War rewatch I
discovered something about barf it you
know I've been able to shut up about an
extremely costly method of hijacking the
hippocampus to clear traumatic memories
in this moment tells us why this scene
at Civil War is so important to Tony
Stark's character development in the MCU
yes I was a bit rough on civil war in my
opinon saga ranking many of you might
never forgive me and some failing to see
that I gave this movie perfect scores on
action and world building but instead
fixated on the fact that I just liked
other MCU movies a bit more have
incessantly badgered me ever since with
comments and tweets threatening to unsub
and trashing every word I've spoken
about Marvel know what it's fine it's
fine it's fine one of my disconnects
with civil war was how out of character
Tony Stark is the screenwriters have
admitted they really just wanted to do a
Captain America 3 movie they felt a bit
hamstrung by the studio forcing them to
include Tony Stark and Peter Parker in
their movie overall they totally pulled
it off although Tony's actions do
contradict themselves like Shireen the
others on hurting kids one moment and
the next moment recruiting a child into
a war zone but now looking back Tony's
uncharacteristic divergence is what many
fans loved about him in this movie I
believe his pukey decisions can be
explained largely by Barth because by
hijacking the hippocampus sparf rewired
how Tony processes memories Worf does
not give a historical record but a
biased subjective account of how our
mind reframes the past Tony even admits
us that's how we should happen in truth
Tony never actually said goodbye to his
parents this way but that is how our
brains process memories as I pointed out
in our breakdown of Captain Marvel when
we remember something we're not
remembering the event as it happened
we're remembering how we felt the last
time we thought about that event our
brains are biologically wired to reframe
the past
in a way that makes us stronger in the
present but barf bypasses that natural
process to revisit those painful
memories and steal in them obsess over
them like in HBO's Watchmen to overdose
on nostalgia this was an abrupt pivot
for Tony after age of Ultron which
defined him as future obsessed [ __ ]
himself after a doomsday premonition
playing God and foreshadowing in games
titled bad up there that's a cheating
game but barf reprogrammed Tony into a
nostalgic who learns the wrong lessons
from history this isn't gonna change
what happened
I don't care he killed him you could say
bark just fried his brain but this is
something we all go through at some
point in our lives
suddenly triggered by a past trauma that
we can't control
Hawkeye even calls Tony out the futurist
is here he sees all he knows what's best
for you whether you like it or not and I
pointed out my breakdown that this is a
meta dig at Robert Downey's juniors
album but it goes even deeper for Tony's
character as a futurist how he screwed
them by being a future obsessed tinkerer
and age of Ultron and now he screws them
by being past obsessed he's unstuck in
time and he stays Restless through
endgame pepper acknowledges his insomnia
but why do people Torres and this movie
sticks the landing so well because it
Criss crosses Tony and Capps trajectory
cap was a man out of his time and game
brought him home
Tony begins a saga living in the moment
then becomes an obsessed futurist then
an obsessed nostalgic but then finds the
real equivalent of barf saying goodbye
to his actual father not a holographic
skewed projection of Howard finally
allowing Tony to rest you can miss it
so does this raise civil war in my
rankings maybe look like memories our
feelings about each of these movies
aren't based on objective truths but on
our personal connections to them if you
liked it more than me you're not wrong
but I'm also not wrong for liking
something less than you did so let's
just get back to the subtle overlooked
details that make all of these movies
great in theories for where they could
be headed next shall we join in this
discussion on discord by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash new rock
stars follow me on instagram at EA vos
follow new rock stars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching and hey if you missed my
old running [ __ ]
here's a throwback for you last time I
trusted someone boom
[Music]